[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the biggest change can come from the
most unexpected individual
with the audience at your fingertips
all you need
is a little push
this is my moment this is what it's all
about relax matey
you got this
okay
is this recording i guess so
hey
zuke
uh give me a minute
shake it off shake it off
your hair is fine come on this is our
television debut
yeah uh yeah i'm here are you guys ready
okay zuke stand here right here good and
i'll be at this corner just like how we
practiced gotcha all right this is gonna
be awesome i'm going to start the
recording now
it's happening time to get famous
please state your name and introduce
yourself briefly
hey
the names matey
i wheel the guitar and he is zook and he
plays the drums
and together we're bunk bed junction
hey zook there sure has been quite a lot
of electronic music in the city lately
that's true mate but you know this city
still lacks a certain something don't
you think absolutely me luckily for you
guys we have the perfect fix why don't
you tell them
why me we're bunk bed junction and we're
going to
we're going to junka um in their bunker
no wait it's that's right zook we're
gonna bunk up we're gonna junk up and
we're gonna bam in your faces we're
bringing back rock this long forgotten
art used to be the backbone of vinyl
city you know so be ready to listen to
our super tasty rips off okay cut that's
a good take oh that's it
yes we got what we needed now please
make your way to the audition stage just
follow the arrows thank you no thank you
so much that was mighty sea next
how could you forget your lion zook it's
bunka then jungkook and bam in your
faces i can't help it as soon as the
camera started rolling i was just wow
the lights were just so intense man
oh sorry about the crates we haven't had
time to move them yet just make your way
around them will ya not a problem sir
don't screw this one up okay we have to
look good in front of the world
yeah i hear you maybe this time okay
we're almost there remember be nice to
the judges
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready
why hello youtube
wow
hello tatiana
right and you are
we're bunk bed junction
bunk bed junction yes because you see
nsr needs more fans so we're gonna build
a new junction right into your highway
so that more people can join this
awesome full party
bunk bed junction
clever i hope you put as much thought
into your music as you did with your
band name
so what will you play for us today
oh it's something the city needs we're
playing
rock
say again rock we're here to bring it
back to the top just like how cool fyra
did a long time ago
really very well then
show me what you've got
it's time too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good and what about you other guy do
just flaunt your hair all day i play the
drums
initiate the second phase
[Music]
yeah i got this
[Music]
how's that
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
take this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very good
now let's see both of you use the skills
to power up the quasar
initiate the final phase
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
uh
uh
wow
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
yes
we did it we finished the course thank
you thank you oh there's so much
electric in this room how do you think
it went
brilliantly thought you'd say that
fellas what do you think
[Music]
well one out of six ain't too bad
hey
now wait a minute there
can you just listen to
zook say something um
okay this is
hold on hold on
i'll be blunt
you came here for us to judge you
and it looks like my artists have spoken
you have no future in show business what
but
but we we managed to finish the arena
and we we reserve the right to reject
you
even if you finish the course
we have the final say in everything
that's not fair please we run on talent
not fairness this edition is held to
find the next best musician who meets
our standards of excellence and you
certainly didn't qualify
well that's rich coming from a bunch of
wannabe artists
see that x
it means you're done
if i were you i would swallow my pride
and use this time to rethink my career
you can't do this to me i just did no
i'm an artist i'm a performer a
performer i belong on this stage okay
i've heard enough thank you very much
off you go you haven't heard the last of
me okay what do you know about rock i
bet you never even held a guitar in your
life
okay listen honey you think you can just
walk in here and drag us all into your
silly fantasy you are so naive to think
that rock is still relevant
stop living in the past
there is only one music in demand right
now and that is
edm
the age of rock is over
edm rules this city
[Music]
oh yeah
well how about you take all these exes
and shove them up
they your do this to us it's not cool
super not cool can't believe they called
us naive right that was bulldozer
bulldozer you hear me i feel you man i
do
listen
i know this didn't go as you planned you
think but it's not good getting worked
up over an empty stomach
why don't we head back first and grab
some burgers on me
fine leave this to me
[Music]
[Music]
think you are skilled at music
think you have what it
[Music]
to join the takes
admission
today
[Music]
we can now enjoy
bringing water
[Music]
hey look we're on tv isn't that great
i think this is a good time for us to
reflect back at our shortcomings
knowing an sr they probably have
unimaginably high standards when it
comes to picking their candidates
[Music]
wait
did you see that
we powered the croissant to almost full
capacity hmm
that is odd those lying idiots how could
they scrap us when we outperformed all
the other contestants
this is totally rigged
we need to take action but there's
nothing we can do about it there's
always something we can do zuke believe
me
if you say so me
[Music]
ah
vinyl city
i'll never grow tired of seeing this
you know
maybe we're being too hard on nsr
just look at how much this city has
thrived ever since they took over oh no
zuke you did not just say that come on i
know it sucks that they didn't pick us
but
i like to believe that they did it based
on fair unbiased judgment people of
vinyl city this is tatiana
in light of the recent abysmal
performance of a certain door that we
all have the unfortunate pleasure of
having to sit through i would like to
announce that rock music is hereby
banned from future lights up editions
for a better prospect of winning we
suggest that you stick to what works
edm
remember
we strive through
order
order leads to progress in vinyl city
that is all have a pleasant evening
what
what the slimy possum did she say oh
dear zuke
this discrimination is so obvious
nsr can't do something like this who do
these people think they are wait it's
freaking unfair there must be a rational
explanation
[Music]
dopey
we gotta fix this right now
hey stop overreacting look around you
nsr may be jerks but you can't deny that
they're doing a great job at governing
the city
yes
if i could see your face i'd punch it
[Music]
what
no wait you see that i don't believe it
our city's backup energies only supplied
to the elites of nsr
that's messed up
first they rejected us
then they denied a right to rock out
and now they think they can keep the
energy from the general public
this is wrong
this is an absolute abuse of power
i hate to say this but i think you might
be on to something finally you're making
sense so tell me
tell me
what are we gonna do to someone who
messes with the good people of vinyl
city
oh we're gonna bunk up we're gonna junk
up and we're gonna bam in their faces
yes
now you're talking
[Music]
[Music]
down there
looks like dj's subatomic supernova is
prepping for a performance perfect
all right zook
this is it
today we stand up against nsr are you
with me
to the very end mae
what do you propose we do
we are gonna hijack their concert
no more injustice it's time we fight edm
with the power of rock the music
revolution starts right now
[Music]
let's rock a talk
[Music]
billions upon billions of organisms
reside on this tiny planet
each meticulously designed to fulfill
their given purpose yet you
barely reach the cusp of mediocrity you
can't even handle simple satellite
launch procedure
such incompetence it's not rocket
science
i mean it is but
can someone fetch me some fresh mr dodo
ice pops this one's all melted
great
what else could possibly go wrong today
what are you nsr people doing we're not
getting enough electricity and all you
guys do is party who are these two have
they purchased the privileged parts to
converse with me huh
you don't remember us bunk bed junction
that's who we are and we're here to stop
nsr from controlling everything the
people of final city deserve to know
what rock is about rock
fascinating
that is fascinating your limited
aspirations your misplaced efforts
you're my meal
pluto
once thought to be a planet of the solar
system but no longer is
what
he just said about us was bad right
well being a dwarf planet is not
necessarily a bad
your intellect is strikingly shallow as
everyone else's what i'm saying is that
you plutonians are no longer relevant
say what so you think your music is so
relevant lies it don't you know who i am
i
am
dj subatomic supernova
my music will reach the furthest corners
of the galaxy what have you done today
simpletons
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dominance over final city ends today in
the sun
maybe
my music
highly
all my music will ripple to the rims of
the universe and back
[Music]
uh
[Music]
sweetly
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
impossible
impossible impossible impossible to
surrender dj broken record silence you
have very barely scratch the surface of
my brilliance
i am done stooping to your level of
idiocy hey come on man i understand
perfectly what you're trying to do
[Applause]
[Music]
or maybe not
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
leave this
[Music]
huh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
uh
[Music]
insects
your endeavors mean nothing with a
billion stars and a thousands upon
thousands of climates
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
there's only one way to end this right
you are duke
green
[Music]
shout
life
[Music]
[Music]
and pluto is still relevant
yeah hear me
[Music]
what's a pluto anyway
dj subatomic supernova come in what is
going on down there
i'm sorry but the dj is currently out of
commission would you like to leave a
message what who do you guys think you
hold on
i remember you you're those
troublemakers from the lightsaber
edition uh-huh
junction and we're here to bring back
rock
you can't be serious you better believe
it we're not stopping till we claim our
faith and bring change to the system
yeah
this city has had enough of your
tyrannical control it's time we give the
people what they want stop the theatrics
you think you're better than me i've
said it before and i'll say it again the
age of rock is over that's where you're
wrong and today's win is proof that the
power of rock is stronger than ever what
do you say to that huh
persistent piece of
well
fine you want to take this road i say
bring it on we have the force to deal
with the likes of you we fight with
order and you have no place in our
system
if that's what you stand for then we
want no part of your stupid regimen it's
time we fight for fairness for the
people of vinyl city we fight for the
little guys
sook come here put your hand next to
mine huh oh
okay what are you doing just hold up
your pinky finger oh like this now put
your hand next to mine no the other side
oh okay a bit more to the right no my
right but i was moving to your right no
you just ah never mind move left like
this more left left left left
for the little guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
last night a sabotage at club
planetarium has resulted in an
unexpected change of leadership the
authorities have identified the group
behind the interference as bunk bed
junction an indie rock duo
the band was led by a guitarist who goes
by the name of mayday followed by her
drumming accomplice zuk
sources say they hijacked dj's subatomic
supernovas concert close to midnight
which subsequently led to nsr's first
district loss in years however tatyana
reassures everyone that the launch of
the new nsr satellite supervised by dj
subatomic supernova went smoothly
despite the takeover the loss of the
kostek district is but a minor setback
to nsr our launch was deemed a success
the nsr satellite is set to reach its
course in orbit soon which will mark
great you owe me a tv mate those nsr
buffoons we managed to defeat an artist
of theirs but somehow they still win did
you have to punch the tv though we ain't
got money to spend on another one listen
to me zook
our revolution is set on a long and
difficult path so sacrifices must be
made for the greater good no tv is going
to
oh hey i got a text message
zuk zuk
i think we just got our first fan say
what now his name is cliff and he has a
lot of nice things to say about us
listen to this
your exceptional skills at playing your
instruments while simultaneously
entertaining the crowd is absolutely
astounding why are you making that
accent he says he wants to arrange a
meeting tonight isn't that exciting zuke
our first fan meetup yeah that's nice
but right now we need to figure out our
next plan of action like how to defeat
nsr he says he knows how to defeat nsr
oh
he did zuke this guy is our biggest fan
atm
i propose we see what he has to say we
have nothing to lose right
well
um
yeah sure why not awesome
let me just reply
[Music]
so how did he get your number i don't
know
okay cliff says to find him at festival
plaza alright let's go see what this guy
is about
[Music]
[Music]
oh
your usual to go
yes and more sugar for me no sugar for
mine please
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you rock stars i saw the audition
you put out some great vibes can't
believe you got disqualified
neither can i we obviously rocked it
come sit down for a drink or two
my treat thanks for the offer but we've
got some place to go another time then
rock stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
greetings mayday and zuke
you're cliff
indeed i am
oh i almost didn't recognize you
your photo
well never mind hello
glad to finally meet you both in person
a real pleasure
pleasure zara's cliff
i'm a huge fan of bunk bed junction or
you can say i'm your biggest number one
fan
i just wanted to let you two know your
gig with the dj was beyond cool i'm all
for what you're doing nsr's wake up call
is long overdue
right
i knew we weren't the only ones who felt
this way
definitely not
in fact there is much i'd like to offer
in support of your efforts
speaking of which didn't you pick up
something after defeating dj subatomic
you mean
this yes yes
the platinum disc
every nsr artist has one
having it in possession means you are
the new charter for this district and
you have
control over it
go ahead place the platinum disc over
there at the dock then play your music
ordinary
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
on a journey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cool stuff
congratulate now all you have to do
other concerts in the other districts
by doing so you you want a free vinyl
city from nsr right of course
then you need to beat the remaining nsr
artists and take it
that's all i have for now
meet me here again if you require my
future assistance here
you've done so yeah you're always
welcome to hang out with really now
don't mind if i do it's over at the
don't worry uh okay isn't this a great
we're not alone in this we have allies
now
[Music]
[Music]
before you go it would be an honor i'd
love to hear your intel cliff what do
you have for us right
acoustica will be your next i hope
you're up to date with the digital space
wait that photo ah the digital idol
she's really bad did you say digital
so she's not even real and she's topping
charts nsr signs on anyone who has the
fame to benefit them
but just to be clear we're fighting a
fictional character right yes
sayo will be tricky to get close to
considering her form
but behind every creation is a creator
and this applies to saiyu too
and that's how we'll beat her take these
and remember she is not constrained by
real world logic
so be prepared for anything all righty
good luck
[Music]
by the way can't help but yes
cool fun ah cliff you just open it the
band she started the ghoulings was way
ahead of its time nobody took rock
seriously until they came along he
trailblazed to stardom and immediately
took vinyl city by storm
oh man yep please tell me you went to
their gigs i did
you got to see the ghoulings live
i'm so jelly so jelly tell me what was
cool what was she like
she got the jeans
she's got the sunglasses she's got the
flaming hair she's got the looks the
spunk
and she had them all
that girl was rocking it i tell you
shook the stage like she absolutely
owned it
she didn't need to change
she was oh cliff it's such a shame that
the coolings got disbanded and cool fyra
faded into obscurity shortly after she
does deserve better and you know what
cliff that's where you come in oh that's
the plan young lady
we're gonna smack tatiana to the side
and reignite cool fire's legacy once and
for all
the story of the universe is beyond
ordinance
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i win
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
the galaxy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
into the imagination unfettered by
ordinary limits
presenting
dj subatomic
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at
[Music]
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
leave this to me
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
it's my turn
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sticks up
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
drum solo
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
drum solo
huh
[Music]
[Music]
ready
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
what a dreamy place oh my welcome
friends are you here to receive the
sweet honey bubbles of my angelic voice
what sweet honey bubbles
no way we're here to bring rock back to
vinyl city and wait this is ridiculous
i can't believe i'm talking to this
thing she's not even real
shh mei don't say the r word it's a very
taboo subject in this district
the r
word
you mean
real
look at her silk
she's not real
but i am real
but there are many factors to consider
so
we're here to fight all right dude snap
out of it and you you're still not real
less stop more rocks oh you're so me
how could you not take me seriously
look at me
please like i have no choice but to
defeat you with the power of love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey how about you come down here and
face us i hate when we can love
love is the most powerful power in the
world
[Music]
she looks
cute
catch me
hey come back here
[Music]
i want to pinch her cheeks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
please take me seriously
[Music]
oh
sing and dance with me okay
one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening to me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow
[Music]
up
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop running away from you
through them i can relate to my feelings
with all my fans around the world
everyone
okay
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
drum solo
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
read this to me
[Music]
uh foreign
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
made up our minds
whoa
what is
this mermaid idol
uh
wow
ah
[Music]
there's only one way to end this okay
okay let's just get rid of this thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
why that door sure looks inviting
shall we then
junction on the bridge
[Music]
you guys are quite a talented bunch but
there are bigger things at play here and
you kids shouldn't get involved
stay in school do your homework and most
importantly
don't ever turn cyou into that thing
again come on mae
let's go home all right sayonara
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
zuke and he plays the drums
oh big junction that's who we are
and we're here to stop nsr from
controlling everything
there's only one music in demand right
now and that is
edm
the people of final city deserve to know
what rock is about it's time we fight
edm with the power of rock the music
revolution starts right now
i
am
dj subatomic supernova
what have you done today simpletons
you're disrupting our music revolution
man let's get this over with
[Music]
green light
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one two three
all night
[Music]
you ready zook
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you